what is going on everybody welcome to
part 12 of our Python with PI QT for GUI
application tutorial video series in
this video we're going to be talking
about a couple of things one is I'm a
color picker and the other one is going
to be a quick exhibition of the calendar
widget because it has one and it's like
a cherry on top needs to throw it in
it's really simple to toss it into your
application so we're going to do that so
uh coming on down into our home and
basically right here is where we're
going to add another option and this is
going to be to change the background
color we could change the font color if
we want it but it's a little harder to
see than if you change like the
background color of some text so that's
what we're going to do here so first of
all first of all our starting color is
just going to be black so color will
just say is we'll just start it with
zero zero zero and in fact let's go like
this and we start that it's a cutie
gooey color so cutie gooey Q color like
that and then what we're going to want
to do is first we'll have a font color
and font color is equal to Qt GUI Q
action and this one will be a font BG
color and then self and then we're going
to do font color dot trigger connect so
stuff you've already seen before self
dot color picker okay so we're going to
need a color picker method that we've
already figured out immediately and then
we're gonna stew self dot a toolbar add
action font color okay so now all we
have to do is add in our color picker
function or method rather but also let's
add in a calendar just because we are
that awesome so let's do it right at the
bottom before self dot show and we're
just going to do something like this Cal
equals cutie GUI QC calendar widget
self then we'll do Cal that move
whoops cow move and we're going to move
it to five hundred two hundred so to be
actually cut off the screen of the
initial but will resize to see it and
then cow dot resize will make it two
hundred by two hundred so that adds a
calendar but also before we load up this
widget let's go ahead and make our color
picker where did we stuff it here it is
color picker method so define color
picker and of course we pass in self as
we always do and then we're going to say
color equals the Qt GUI for cue color
dialog dialog dot get color so that will
pop up our dialog now what we want to do
once we've done that once we've found
color so when we as in the definition of
color we're calling into being this get
color so this color picker once we have
color what we're going to do is we're
gonna say self dot style choice and what
is it so that choice probably like that
I think style yes self dot style choice
dot set style sheet and then we're going
to say and this is supposed to be in
quotes Q widget and then we're gonna say
back around - background - color is
equal to what and we'll say percent s
some string formatting here and then %
color dot name ok so there's quite a few
things that we're showing here so
obviously we've got the calendar and
we've got you know adding the toolbar of
the method on that that's we've already
seen that this is for the color picker
but then also we're seeing something new
and that set style sheet so the style
sheets gonna allow you to customize
things within your application which is
pretty cool and you can set the style
sheet for individual things and then you
can also set set style sheets for a much
larger global things
so keep that in mind if you're
interested in really customizing your
windows you're probably going to be
peeking into this stuff a little more
often but anyway let's go ahead and save
and run that and see what happens
well first of all we get an error oh
yeah no comma there next try again
unexpected in that oh my goodness all
right there we go
all right well our checkboxes in the way
first of all so let's fix that checkbox
where did we hide this checkbox move
let's make it 300 great and it still
says shrink window let's go and make it
in large wind didn't realize we were
still saying that cool so that works we
enlarged the window and there is our
calendar pretty cool I'm filming this on
well shouldn't be the 10th supposed to
be the 11th did it default attend my
blind no okay I said it was the 11th
anyway you got this awesome calendar we
just go into the future and we can
select things and then actually when you
select things you can actually store
those so you can return the dates that a
user might select so keep that in mind
the other thing is now of course the
font color so let's click on that and
bam we got this color picker we didn't
have to code any of this that's awesome
so you've got that and now let's pick on
another green or something we'll hit OK
and now that changed the background of
that and then we could change it again
to you know pink or purple whatever you
want to call that color and then maybe
red and and so on so you can see that we
can actually change things dynamically
there and we have this awesome foot cut
this color picker wow I've had a really
hard time saying that you can you've got
this awesome thing already basically
pre-made for you so again color picker
you know you're not going to use it in
every application but you're going to
use it in a large number of application
types and so that's pretty cool that
they've got one built-in for you so
we've got font and that color picker so
that's pretty cool anyway that's that
for this tutorial in the next tutorial
we're going to be talking about the
editor's so there are ways you know
there's text fields but then there's a
way to actually make an editor see we
could actually make something a lot like
IDL II that we're coding in right now
you might be coding in something else
but there's an editor widget which will
actually make the entire screen
basically an editor just like this so
that's pretty cool
so that's what I'm going to be showing
you guys in the next tutorial and then
we'll be talking about opening files and
then even saving files with your editors
will actually end up making a full-on
text editor which is pretty cool so
anyways that's it for this tutorial if
you have questions or comments please
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions until
next time